benvenuti sanità stories oggi video mag
bank e sapete ne ho fatto solo uno
schema è vitale in cui mangiavamo il
sushi 15 con sono solo a vitale non c'è
posso mangiarmi tutto innanzitutto ho
deciso di fare questo mag bank per
passare un po di tempo assieme
se non avete ancora mangiato potete
magari preparare tutto e poi mangiare
assieme a me oppure potete tenere questo
video come sottofondo mentre studiate
mentre fate qualcosa io adori video
parlati ti posto rita in cui raccontano
le cose perché mi piace tenere in
sottofondo mentre faccio qualcosa e tare
nel frattempo le varie storie
comunque oggi andro non solo mangiare
questa pizza che è una margherita con
porcini
poi ho anche un mio tiramisù e ho messo
la candelina per fare un po più come se
fossimo assieme al ristorante e vi
racconterò delle mie brutte figure
quindi qualche figura imbarazzante che
non vi ho mai raccontato
allora innanzitutto prima a salso questa
pizza
vediamo come voi sì ma in genere non la
prendo con i funghi perché mina usiamo
dopo un po sono così sono super moni
fatemi sapere voi cosa avete mangiato a
pranzo cena o finissimo quindi è il
momento più opportuno per fare una band
quando il super fame cosa c'è di più
mondo della pizza davvero buona
buonissima allora iniziò con la prima
brutta figura non è proprio una brutta
figura è che sta succedendo la candela
da un po vabbè
una situazione particolare errore
in pratica era dal parrucchiere era tipo
12 anni fa se non sbaglio era un anno fa
era dal parrucchiere in italia per
un'america e io ho fatto solamente il
taglio quindi ho fatto in fretta invece
la mia amica doveva fare lo shatush
degradé e quindi ci hanno messo tipo 2
ore e mezzo
allora io una volta che ho finito sono
stata seduta nelle poltroncine stavano
un po parlando con la parrucchiera
perché non ho di parchi super simpatici
tra l'altro super bravi
c'era la mamma faceva la parrucchiera e
può essere alla figlia c'era anche la
nonna al bellissimo perché erano tutti
in famiglia
vabbè comunque c'era la figlia della
parrucchiera appunto che venga una
bambina piccolina quindi niente io stavo
lì aspettando nelle poltroncine la
bambina stava di fronte a me però non mi
ha mai guardato diciamo aveva mai fatto
un tablet stava continuamente guardando
il tablet quindi era proprio presa
tantissimo dal tablet quindi non gliene
fregava di chi c'era intorno sicuramente
anche perché stanno stato orecchie
restare abituata che entra nel destro
sacco di persone insomma non interessa
guardare tutti avessimo comunque io
stavo lì sul telefono stavo già stasera
da un sacco di tempo quindi ero un po
scocciato
a questo punto è stato stranissimo
veramente è stato veramente strano sento
la mia voce a volume altissimo mi
sviluppa realizzata per un momento ha
pensato ma maniera nella mia testa
sapete perché non è normale sentire la
propria voce da un parrucchiere questa
sommaria nella mia testa che questa cosa
ha sentito e poi la sento ancora e la
bambina stava guardando un mio video non
so perché proprio in quel momento in
questa ora quel mio video il volume la
alzato tantissimo quindi non so se
magari la bambina sta
era che ero io e quindi alzato il volume
apposta per non mi ha mai guardato
quindi adesso per strano comunque con un
altissimo e mi sentivo io che dicevo per
il prossimo scherzo dovete usare la
nutella e ho detto io lavoravo il video
degli scherzi a scuola alla questa
bambina è la piccola piccola avrà avuto
forse 4 o 5 anni si sui cinque anni
perché io sono rimasta così un po
paralizzata che non sapevo bene che cosa
fare ho pensato magari ora vado a
salutarlo non lo so le dico a sykes e
guardano mio video mentre penso cosa
fare è infatti un po anche paura che la
mia amica senta la mia voce inizi perché
lo zio michè tipo è di quelle che
parlano un sacco dicono tutto e quindi
avrebbe iniziato a dire mi sarei sentito
l'imbarazzo un'altra cosa stranissima
che succede a un solo punto manca la
luce quindi si spegne tutto penso che
può succedere
spesso dal parrucchiere perché così
molta elettricità tra phone
eccetera l'attesa sta raffreddando mi
devo abituare a fare meglio e raccontare
mentre mangio non posso aspettare troppo
comunque manca la luce
siamo al buio oddio se ci ripenso mi
vergogno ancora comunque siamo al buio e
penso che siccome mancata la luce se sia
tagliata nella connessione ipod perché
la mia voce si è interrotta quindi non
ha più visto quel video
[Musica]
quindi c'erano appunto le parrucchiere
la mamma della bambina che stavano
sistemando una barretta per la luce
riattaccano la luce e la mammina va
dalla mamma o c'era tipo una sezione
dietro quindi io non le vedevo
non è un caso se posso aspettare però mi
devo ricordare di mangiare si sono una
di quelle persone che l'affare grosso lo
sono uno spreco in genere non ho già
detto allora la bambina cosa alla mamma
io cerco di sentire cosa dice
per capire se l'estate essendo tipo a ma
quella ragazza che se di seduta l'ho
vista fa allora la bambina liscia voglio
rivedere il video stavo guardando b che
sto guardando un video si lamenta che a
quanto pare come è saltata la luce ha
perso il video non so cosa sia successo
nell ipod o comunque la mamma né sestina
spetta ora telo rimento dimmi come si
chiamava quale era questo qui questo qui
è un vino no no no penso e ho pensato
subito ok ora la mamma mi vedrà lì nel
video e di là ma è la stessa ragazza cui
mia madre sta fatemi capelli privato
sbaglio
ora trova il video lo mette ne guarda un
pezzetto perché sento un po di audio e
dice no questo assolutamente tornare
puoi guardare e io di tipo oggi racconta
consumo solo video per bambini non lo
puoi guardare questo tipo di ovaio
sotterrare se mi riconoscono adesso che
offre ha detto che io non voglio bene
per vederli o mio dio penso che abbia
detto così comunque sapete che i miei
video sono adatti ai bambini però magari
siccome la bambina aveva 5 anni e nel
video facevo vedere degli scritti da
fare a scuola ma ovviamente in modo
ironico non per forza che devi farli a
scuola avrà pensato magari andrà farà
questi scherzi a scuola tra l'altro
quello che stava dicendo alla nutella è
quello in cui noi temo la carteggi e
dentro il libro quindi immagino devi
morire nuovamente i due anni si mette a
fare questa cosa scola sarebbe super
divertente però non va bene
quindi io in quel momento era super
imbarazzata perchè non so se mi avesse
riconosciuto ma alla detto quella cosa
quindi se mi avesse riconosciuto poi
avrebbe capito che l'ho io quella che
faceva i video che non andavano bene per
sua figlia si sta raffreddando noi nel
cusato devo mangiare un po di tiro
sapere nei commenti se preferite il
video magma in cui racconto cose oppure
solo storytime quindi che per quanto la
cosa senza mangiare un comando non
sapevo cosa fare la super imbarazzata
con gli ho detto la mia vita stavano
tornando ma mi è stato un anno a sedersi
e la madre stava tornando lì insomma
dove c'ero io ho detto la mia amica
senti io vado a fare un giro poi rientra
tra un po il velo sei finito lei o si va
bene ok perché si stava mettendo
veramente tantissimo però è così che ci
metterò nella tinta insomma quindi sono
uscito a fare un giro e ho pensato ora
che rientra sicuramente ne avranno
parlato non lo sto mi dirà qualcosa bo
vabbè comunque faccio questo giro sarà
anche fresco cui eravamo in un posto che
non conoscevo
quindi niente di nuovo avanti dietro ai
super su cosa allora poi dopo un po mi
sono anche scocciata pistorio in giro
sono rientrate per fortuna avevo finito
praticamente allora un po lato e niente
non mi ha detto niente
la mamma e la bambina non mi ricordo
verano ma non mi hanno detto niente
insomma quindi tuttora non so se
veramente l'hanno capito che ero io
oppure è stata solo una stranissima
coincidenza secondo voi da quello che vi
ho raccontato hanno capito che ero io
perché non lo so ora così strano che la
bambina ha messo poi volume alto e tutto
il resto comunque quest'altro fare
veramente divertente una stranissima
coincidenza per me imbarazzante appunto
dopo che la mamma ha detto che ridere
quando meno bene per la morbida
quindi questa è una delle mie brutte
figure e allora in realtà una lista
enorme di brutta figura perché penso che
sia normale tutti facciamo brutte figure
quindi non vi vergognate non pensate che
c'è qualcosa che non va
voi non vi preoccupate tutti fanno
brutte figure anche le celebrity anche
e attore incantato tutti con brutte
figure quindi non vi preoccupate e
allora ne ho una non posso raccontare
adesso per tutto una a scuola e sono
quasi john piena penso che mi informerò
qua questa rom angelo più tale di
assaggio in tiramisù anche se già mi
sento che sta scoppiando però vi voglio
raccontare questo settore perché magari
aiuteremo che qualcuno di voi ed era a
scuola alle superiori mi sembra in
quinta
ho fatto il linguistico e come molte
persone immagino era terribile in
matematica
da sempre ho sempre avuto insegnanti
dalle medie un insegnante terribile e
quindi non è sempre colpa degli
insegnanti ovviamente però anch'io mi
poteva applicare però avendo un
insegnante terribile di quei estrema
paure che non gli piaccio a insegnare
quella materia influisce anche comunque
sono stata fortunata perché l'ultimo
anno mi sembra che fosse l'ultimo anno
non mi ricorderà il quarto il quinto
comunque a preparo un nuovo professore
bravissimo bravissimo dolcissimo spero
che non servono adesso questo video
perché fino e molto compromettente
eravamo tutti innamorati di lui perché
era super dolce
non lo so era anche carino era diverso
dai soliti professori quindi ovviamente
tra l'altro un fattore linguistico ma ci
straniera nuovo quasi tutte ragazze
c'erano solo due ragazzi e molti
insegnanti avevamo erano quasi tutte
donne
quindi ogni volta che c'era lui noi
eravamo tutti con gli occhi a cuoricino
era votata innamorato e poi lui era
dolcissimo era un super paziente super
bravo non si arrabbia ma meno che non
fossi una che comunque rispondeva ma le
cose però non si arrabbia ma quasi mai
era veramente bravo molto bravo anche
insegnando quindi decisamente fantastico
siamo stati siamo state fortunate d'aver
solo noi che io sia migliorata in
matematica però perché ormai mi mancava
qualsiasi base veramente homo tutti
disperate perché oltre all'altro non sto
mangiando c'era la verifica di
matematica una verifica importantissima
che avevamo difficoltà insomma perché è
un po normale immagino pervenute lo
scientifico penso che tutte le persone
che conosco hanno avuto difficoltà in
matematica vabbè comunque eravamo
disperati perché non sapevamo fare che
contrasti niente solo alcuni sono quelli
bravi della classe in sommario si può
non fare nomi dico che cosa stavamo
studiamo quel periodo
allora che cosa abbiamo pensato
aspettare perché questo è il fantastico
praticamente una delle mie migliori
amiche valentina ha una gemella sabbia
che stava nell'altra classe e lo stesso
professore attenzione per se starete
pensando che sono scambiate non po
diversa la cosa allora cos'è successo
il professore ha fatto la verifica prima
nella classe della gemella della mia
amica claudia cos'è un patto claudia di
e spero veramente che nessuno dei mix
tra bari che sorride
veramente incriminante comunque ha
copiato tutti gli esercizi che venivano
richiesti nella verifica tutti e noi
avevamo la best di quel giorno dopo
passato gli esercizi
oddio ma tra l'altro che in genio che
eravamo veramente
vabbè ci ha passato di esercizi nei
discorsi li aveva passati solo a me a
qualcun'altro tutta la classe
ripensando il solo mi viene tutta la
classe perché eravamo ponte non
pensavamo ma è ovvio che se facciamo
tutto perfetto storia rende racconto
però non mi ricorre funzionalmente penso
fosse tutta la classe
comunque abbiamo chiesta una super prova
di risolverli poi ci siamo trascritti e
volevamo i risultati alla verifica cioè
eravamo felicissimi ma anche ce l'avrà
un fatto un po esotico 10 il matematico
come se non fosse strano da un giorno
all'altro cambiare così no come se fosse
stupido il professor fretta
allora arriva il giorno della verifica
io ero felicissima perché ero a posto
avevo già tutti gli esercizi tutte le
risposte facciamo la verifica è tutto e
lo consegnamo poi sapete che la verifica
si consegna questi aspettate il
professore le corregga e poi te li
riconsegna allora attenzione perché ci
sono stati momenti di panico ha
riconsegnato le verifiche se si ripensa
avuto un palco a allora io prendo la
verifica la guardo non mi ricordo che
voto che si preso non mi farò comunque
più del 6
e già per me era fantastico
ecco la verifica e c'era scritto in
rosso
questo esercizio non c'era nella
verifica puntini puntini puntini di
domanda o mio dio no no non mi dire non
mi dire sono stata così stupida
in pratica io ho copiato tutte le gli
esercizi le risposte come ce l'avevano
dati senza controllare che nella
verifica che ci ha dato il professore
mancava in realtà un esercizio perché ce
l'ha data un po diversa però senza un
esercizio e come cavolo gli spiegavo
come cavolo mi potevo giustificare
veramente come potevo dire mi è venuto
all'improvviso che se sfizio mente così
mi sono inventata una formula lo scritto
nella verifica e poi l'ho risolto da
sola così per far vedere che sono brava
no non c'era veramente nessuna scusa
plausibile che cavolo potevo dirgli tra
l'altro poi pensa sia ancora così dopo
che il professore ti consegna la
benefica tu devi andare a
riconsegnargliela alla cattedra e lui ti
dice qualcosa tipo come mai hai fatto
questo ti ho dato questo voto per questo
motivo eccetera eccetera
quindi io ho avuto l'incubo per i tipo
quei dieci minuti ero tipo no è la fine
la fine
alla fine è la figlia della mia terriere
scolastica non potrò mai giustificare
quel terrore che cavolo di di cori manco
il silenzio visto niente manovra
sicuramente capito perché si ricorda che
quello esercizio era nell'altra beni che
in cui c'è la gemella di valente la
forte o chiama il mio nome dato a
riconsegnare la verifica di
collettamento il bocciolo di discutere
tra loro in forza anche se appunto era
un angelo progressivo la poggia sulla
cattedra
lui mi guarda e sorride e basta tuttora
non so che cosa che cosa volesse dire
nel senso non so perché non mi ha detto
niente non so se questo riso voleva dire
lo so benissimo che vi siete passati la
verifica ma non fa niente però
ovviamente non poteva metterlo avrebbe
dovuto annullare tutti tutte le
verifiche rifarle quindi capisco il
motivo per cui non lo abbia detto se è
per questo era ancora più un angelo
oppure oppure non se n'è accorto ma un
professore di matematica grigie
professori di matematica sono molto
logici e razionali e molto attenti i
dettagli non penso proprio che non
saresti accorto c'è sì se ne è accorto
perché ha scritto quello medico magari
non ha fatto il collegamento con che la
cordata veli ma non penso proprio quindi
questa è stata una figura terribile mi
ricordo il panico poi in realtà continua
non so se raccontarvi continuo adesso
magari provo il tiramisù che vi racconto
com'è andata alla verifica dopo dovremo
interessa gestirà mi stupì racconto
velocemente come è andata poi alle altre
verifiche in pratica un po di tempo dopo
avevamo un'altra verifica sempre di
matematica con lo stesso professore e
noi quanto siamo intelligenti veramente
quanto stupide
abbiamo pensato di usare lo stesso
trucchetto ma veramente ti rendi conto
solo quando cresci poi di quanto di
quattro ere ingenuo da piccola comunque
abbiamo deciso di dare allo stesso
tocchetto quindi ci siamo fatti spostare
tutti gli esercizi dal claudia e avevamo
tutti gli esercizi appunto questa volta
avevo detto no devo stati super atleta
che diesel si stiano lì lo devo metterne
uno in più all'ora quindi ci prepariamo
tutti gli esercizi anche questa volta
eravamo tutti molto borgo preparati
perché veramente non lo so non so come
fanno le persone che sono bravo in
matematica
però per me è sempre stato veramente
complicato proviamo queste trame subiti
[Musica]
buonissimo dolcissimo troppo buono
provano tutte felicissime perché avevamo
già le risposte quindi insomma non erano
preoccupate per niente a questa volta
sono sicura che se li aveva tutta la
classe perché c'eravamo tutti messi
d'accordo c'eravamo tutti tutti gli
esercizi e tutte le risposte ai tanti
problemi irrisolti
non ci posso credere arriva il
professore e chi da le verifiche
noi siamo già pronti con i fogli sotto
con tutte le risposte
guardiamo la verifica e scoppiamo a
ridere tutti assieme tutti assieme
iniziamo a ridere come dei pazzi aveva
cambiato tutti gli esercizi ovviamente
perché non è stupido se ci penso adesso
al tempo pensavo mai come affatto
d'accordo ma è ovvio comunque tutti gli
esercizi erano diversi e non so perché
ci è voluta una ridarella perché ci
siamo resi conto che era un uomo
spazzati 15 e venuto un sacco da ridere
a tutti questo è cioè presso un
professore che non sapeva cosa stava
succedendo avrebbe chiesto ma perché
state ridendo tutti ma che cosa succede
che per che cosa c'è da ridere
invece lui era silenzioso e tranquillo
ripensando siete secondo me si stava
godendo la scena e per stava ridendo
anche lui dentro un po pensavate di
spiegarmi è addio e quindi abbiamo tutte
accettato il nostro destino di di
fallire miseramente la verifica non
tutte perché alcune erano brave
ovviamente non ce l'abbiamo fatta al
professore magari se l'ha fatta a
passare la prima volta ma questa volta
ovviamente l'inter ha preparato quindi
questa è un'altra mia brutta figura
questa non proprio mia di tutta la
classe praticamente
ma ne avrei tante da raccontare delle
superiori le me che non sono state un
bel periodo per me superiori sono stata
fortunata perché le mie compagne e
compagni erano fantastici tutti eravamo
in ultimo tour.it come avete potuto
sentire già dalla verifica si si
sopportavano comunque tutti la vicenda
ogni tanto c'era qualcuna criticava con
un'altra però cose semplici
fatemi sapere se volete sentire altri
store imbarazzanti ente volete che vi
racconti qualcosa nello specifico
professori strani perché mi hanno avuti
parecchi professori stradio di tutto
quello che pensate io finisco qua se non
viene mal di stomaco lo finisco più
tardi mi ha fatto un sacco pincer e
mangiare con voi raccontare queste cose
è stata sopra divertente è passato un po
di tempo ma è volato e spero che sia
così anche per voi come vi ho detto io
dovevo ascoltare le persone che
raccontano parlare come lei se volete
vederne un altro e ditemi se preferite
storica non mag bank magari vi metto il
sondaggio qua così potete notare che
niente la nave lasciato alquanto casa il
virus criticare per vedere i miei altri
video cliccate su quello che preferite e
buona visione
ciao